[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue et
bienvenue à lou bureau notre confrère sa
libération a été annoncée cet après midi
il était détenu depuis le 1er août en
turquie pour avoir pris des photos bref
pour a refait son travail de reporter on
espère le revoir très vite
au programme ce soir faut-il avoir peur
avez vous peur avez vous peur des
missiles de kim jong-un des explosions
dans le métro de londres
des agressions contre les militaires de
sentinelle on vous pose la question
votre réponse sur les forums du figaro
est aussi sur facebook et bonjour à vous
qui suivez sur tous ses supports hors
parlera ensuite de jean-luc mélenchon et
de la guerre à gauche de la gauche
absent de la fête de l'huma il s'est
confié à marianne on demandera au
directeur délégué de la rédaction ce
qu'il a déclaré ce qu'ils attaquent ce
qu'il défend à l'heure où 68 % des
français pensent que la mobilisation de
cette semaine contre la loi travail est
un échec
révélation du sondage le figaro france
info réalisé par au doxa et dentsu sa
directrice est avec nous pour le
commenter et pour commenter aussi les
embarras de la droite autour de la pma
on parlera aussi de la journée du
patrimoine
plein de choses belles à voir assurément
mais justement est ce que les français
ont les moyens de les entretenir
bonjour à florence bonjour à dominic et
martin qui nous rejoignent sur le forum
du figaro donnez votre avis poser vos
questions et interpeller nos invités
laurence de charette bonjour bienvenue
sur le plateau de filles en live pour
cette première il est éditorialiste au
figaro et directrice de la rédaction du
figaro.fr
eric descout de couture on a parlé de
vous êtes directeur délégué de marianne
qui donc
publie cette semaine ce grand interview
de jean luc mélenchon répond à emmanuel
macron veronica x août
bonjour bonjour de dentsu consulting on
va scruter avec vous l'opinion à travers
tous les sujets qui vont être abordés
autour de 7
au long de cette émission le génie
d'acier journalistes aux pages débats et
opinions du figaro au figaro vox et on
leur rappellera jamais assez auteur du
livre manifeste
adieu mademoiselle adieu mademoiselle et
bonjour l'angoissé en tout cas à
kamaishi au nord du japon ce matin
ainsi qu'à tokyo quand ont retenti ces
bruits
[Musique]
alors en cause un nouveau tir de missile
par la corée du nord à missile
balistique de portée intermédiaire il
aurait pu dit-on atteindre l'île de guam
et sa base militaire américaine
10 heures plus tard explosions dans le
métro de londres un acte terroriste
disent les autorités
là il n'y a que des blessés il n'y a pas
de morts 22 blessés j'ai une question à
vous poser qu'est ce qui vous fait le
plus peur qu est ce qui est le plus
dangereux selon le coup de deux choses
d'abord je pense qu'il faut pas avoir
peur
c'est un principe de vie dans tous les
cas c'est le mien je pense qu'il faut
pas avoir peur a priori ensuite tant
qu'à avoir peur et remporte de la crise
car de l'infarctus ou du cancer
je vois pas la proximité les deux sont
effrayants voilà les deux sont
effrayants il ya une proximité avec le
terrorisme dire que le terrorisme nous
touchons mais vous pensez vraiment que
kim jong un missile nucléaire
vous savez
s'empare du audiard s'était pas les
dingues mais les dames tout est possible
et je pense qu'on est dans une phase à
personnage irrationnelle je pense qu'ils
auront peu je pense qu'à une part
d'irrationalité oui je pense qu'il ya un
côté fois l'amour chez cet individu que
aujourd'hui il peut être prêt tout et je
pense que l'acier je pense qu'il faut
avoir peur parce que dire c'est vrai
qu'on a raison d'avoir peur d'une un
dingue qui a la bombe atomique etc vous
pensez donc vous êtes d'accord non mais
on a raison on a raison il est dingue
vous pensez n'enchante pas qu'il soit un
bon en tout cas la raison d'avoir peur
que la corée du nord possède la bombe
nucléaire et d'ailleurs c'est le mâle
l'humanité les moyens de sa progression
de sa propre auto destruction depuis la
bombe atomique a été inventé et c'est
vrai que ça fait peur et d'ailleurs le
philosophe allemand hans yonath avait
écrit un livre s'appelle le principe
responsabilité dans laquelle dans lequel
il développé l'idée d'une herméneutique
de la peur dixit et que l'humanité ne
vais plus être justement confiante
optimiste en disant voilà toute une
toile et bien l'idée du progrès libéral
était complètement obsolète et que
maintenant on devait en effet avoir une
humanité qui avait droit à avoir peur
est la peur est très bonne conseillère
pas être ministre sans avoir quoi que
l'appareil bonne qu'on se le dise
ambiance c'est un répéteur bien humains
pour se protéger
la question c'est que quelques élus
quels types de peur ça engage à ce
qu'une peur qu'il se transforme en
lâcheté ou en fuite
parce que c'est une peur qui évidemment
est de bon conseil laurence de charette
dans tous les cas je crois chauffeurs
ont pas peur il faut pas être paralysé
mais bon la question vous posiez c'est
finalement ce qu'il est fou
je suis pas si convaincu que ça et parce
que finalement alors il n'y a pas tout à
fait les mêmes codes que nous un
personnage assez atypique c'est mon
plaisir mais à la fois il s'exprime avec
des bombes certes mais il dit des choses
assez clair avec ses bombes ça c'est
cette nuit par exemple nous a dit vaut
sanctions
sam arrêtera pas et deuxièmement
messieurs les américains ge et pavie
sais quoi mais je pourrais donc
finalement il part assez clairement il
est rationnel de pas d'accord avec lyon
je crois qu'il y a relativement
rationnel entre il a un comportement qui
est compréhensible qui est qu'il est
parfois prévisible alors ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'est pas dangereux
ces deux choses sont deux choses
différentes après vous compariez alors
de quoi faut-il avoir le plus peur
finalement je pas sûr que l'on aime
rejette parce que je quitte on n'est pas
dans une guerre de civilisation et non
s'inscrit pas dans la même logique rien
et dans tous les cas ce que montrent ces
deux situations
c'est la base et démocratie et leur
difficulté à agir d'accord
justement quand vous faites comme il dit
qu'il faut pas être dans une guerre de
civilisation c'est que vous établissez
quand même une différence entre les deux
non mais pas du coup l'une enfin on est
pas de même mais pas dans une guerre de
civilisation
donc a priori
si je suis si je vais au bout de votre
logique il faut pas n'a pas tellement de
raison d'avoir peur de kim jong eun
d'avoir raison d'avoir peur d'une guerre
de civilisation oui on aurait tort de ne
pas voir peur du nouveau nucléaire mais
feint de ne pas agir dans les deux cas
on a répondu on ne retourne pas mais il
est vrai que la menace ce qui nous en
cire que chaque veau c'est aujourd'hui
londres
aujourd'hui les militaires attaqué et
c'est notre quotidien et c'est une règle
marien missiles sur la promenade des
anglais la question la question c'est
techniquement c'est moins la peur que
celle de cesson deux menaces différentes
missions de menace très réelle et la
question plutôt que la peur la vida
manguy les deux menaces sont des menaces
distincts la question est une question
politique c'est pas une question jédir
sentimentale de savoir si on a peur ou
pas peur c'est qu'elle est quelles sont
les réponses politiques qu'on peut
apporter politique voire militaire voir
qu'on peut apporter à ces deux menaces
et qu'il faut apporter à ces deux
menaces c'est ça la question qui se pose
c'est quoi la mena la réponse militaire
par exemple kim jong-hun on a critiqué
donald trump justement qui militaire ou
diplomatique militaire ou diplomatique
militaire ou diplomatique c'est c'est
compliqué parce que on voit bien
l'intérêt leleu personnes aujourd'hui
notamment la chine
il ya une c'est une question qui n'est
pas qui ne concerne pas que les
occidentaux loin de là c'est une
question qui est qui et planétaire aussi
consomme jaillir presque d'abord les
voisins de la corée il ya justement une
réunion conseil de sécurité cet après
midi justement pour étudier les réponses
la corée du nord on n'a pas l'impression
que les réponses qui ont été faites qui
sont les alliés des sanctions tout à
l'heure laurent ce sont des cendres des
réponses efficaces
non effectivement ce qu'il souligne
c'est l'impuissance des démocraties face
et une détermination que nous qualifions
de folles et effectivement c'est là on
peut refaire le parallélisme c'est à
dire que finalement ce que ce que les
démocraties n'arrive pas à combattre le
qualifie de fou
de là et on a qualifié king ou de fous
mais parallèlement on peut voir que
malgré tout par exemple entre les états
unis et la corée du nord les relations
diplomatiques ne sont pas interrompues
et on peut encore espérer diplomatique
florence tout dit sur sur le forum du
figaro qu'elle a peur des 2 et rachète
demande qu'est ce que le président de la
corée du nord cherche exactement mais
j'avoue être reconnu comme puissance
nucléaire tout simplement et une
assurance vie pour son régime
mais moi je vois pas comment d'ailleurs
les spécialistes ionis ça paraît
inéluctable de voir le reconnaître de la
commune nord en puissance en tant que
puissance utile donc c'est pas forcément
pour utiliser ses armes nucléaires
c'est pour donner une assurance vie au
régime va finir comme comme comme
kadhafi book saddam hussein est tout
simplement est le seul moyen de protéger
un régime dictatorial d'une agitation
interne ou à une révolution
la peur elle remonte dans les réseaux
les prix des soutes oui je pense que les
internautes reconnaissent le propos de
génie parce que pour eux c'est important
d'avoir peur mais pas peur pour la peur
peur pour se prémunir et faire attention
après le commencement de la sagesse
voilà et les internautes sont beaucoup
plus sage qu'on imagine après le sujet
il est en tout cas le sujet elle était
aussi vous vous posiez la question de
quoi ont-ils le plus peur alors après
c'est toujours pareil
ce qui est proche de soi inquiète plus
donc en fait si on fait un parallèle
entre le sujet de la corée et le sujet
du terrorisme
on parle 100 fois plus du terrorisme que
de l'accord et sur les réseaux sociaux
et globalement ils ont peur ils disent
que c'est effrayant mais il ya un côté
résigné en tant que jasmin il faut vivre
avec
voilà donc c'est une sorte de fatalisme
alors que la corée ils ont l'impression
qu'on peut plus agir que c'est peut-être
plus simple d'agir est comme ça leur
semble plus loin moins dangereux quelque
part parce que comme vous le disiez il
est quand même peu probable qu'un
missile arrive sur paris qu'on entende
ce que les japonais ont malheureusement
entendu ce matin
donc du coup il en parle un peu moins de
2001 qu'il avait des capacités
intercontinentales
en france justement puisque vous parlez
du terrorisme il y à l'opération
sentinelles elle a été remanié hier lors
d'un conseil de défense cela allait
mesures ont été annoncées à leur issue
on n'a pas tellement compris alors ce
matin florence parly la ministre des
armées a essayé de ré expliquer en les
coûts de cette tête au micro de nos
confrères d'europe 1 aujourd'hui 7000
hommes qui peuvent être déployées
jusqu'à 10000 sur instruction du
président la république donc l'objectif
n'était absolument pas de modifier le
format de l'opération sentinelle major
militaire en plus ou en moins
il n'y aura pas de militaires en moins
en revanche ce que nous voulons c'est
faire mieux pour être plus efficace et
comment et bien en rendant ce dispositif
plus flexible plus mobiles - anticipable
et c'est très important parce que ce que
nous voulons éviter c'est que
l'opération sentinelle soit prévisible
je suis content parce que je vois que
paris existe parce que j'avais
l'impression que depuis six mois il ya
une preuve de vie donc je suis rassuré
parce qu'il ya une succession de crises
dans les airs mais j'avais pas vu la
ministre de la défense donc je vois vos
images liste des armes et effectivement
ils ont chargé d'opération donc elles
existent je suis rassuré il ya donc un
ministre des armées
j'ai l'impression que ce gouvernement ne
mesure pas l'état des forces militaires
on a publié une succession de reportages
de l'intérieur parce que il ya eu là du
figaro
le coup de gueule de félicitations parce
que c'est une vraie danse est un vrai
sujet etc
on a publié aussi donc des témoignages
au delà de la de l'histoire du général
de vie des 2 du 14 juillet dernier son
successeur qui a piqué un vrai coup de
gueule qui est passée relativement
inaperçue d'ailleurs c'est assez
surprenant mais il ya un malaise très
profond et un malaise budgétaire il ya
un malaise dans les dents les troupes et
j'ai l'impression quand j'entends ce
discours de madame parler il faut être
que je le réécoute jeté un peu obsédé
par sa trace de vie évidente j'ai pas
compris ce qu'elle disait j'ai
l'impression que ils ne sont pas
capables de parler ni en terme financier
puisque à des questions matérielles ni
en termes de rapport aux humains par
rapport aux troupes françaises
laurence de charette malgré tout
faites-vous l'avocat oui un petit peu
non en fait le gouverement il ya quand
même
position elle prise en étau parce qu'on
voit à la fois que je crois qu'on en est
au 7e 7e agression on voit bien que
malgré tout il ya un message vis-à-vis
des français qui est quand même très
difficile à faire passer on peut pas
leur dire on ne fait rien donc voilà si
elle varié va faire bouger il me semble
que ce n'est pas forcément parce que son
discours champions c'est
incompréhensible parce que la position
n'est pas très difficile à trancher
effectivement entre ne rien demander
militaires et leur demander trop il ya
d'abord leur demandent de plus en plus
ce jeu on leur demande beaucoup sans
cesse sans qu en plus mais c'est vrai
aussi pour les trois ministères
régaliens qui sont au coeur de la lutte
contre le terrorisme la justice
l'intérieur c'est quand même assez
insensé qu'on demande de plus en plus
aux hommes et aux matériels mais surtout
aux hommes et que on constate qu'il ya
des réductions budgétaires
et en plus c'est des gens pour les gens
de l'opération florence vers lille a
démenti ce matin enfin bon elle peut le
démentir mais enfin quand c'est le chef
d'état major qui le dit qui est une fois
et qui le qui le répète et que son
successeur le dit aussi
moi j'aurais plutôt tendance à faire
confiance aux praticiens ce sont des
gens qui risquent leur vie au quotidien
c'est tous les jours donc il ya quelque
chose qui est du domaine du matériel
mais également de l'humain on salue
audrey alex et geci qui nous rejoignent
vous pouvez justement réagir sur cette
question de l'efficacité de l'opération
sentinelle et des moyens qui sont
alloués aux armes et eugénie je vous
voyais
j'avais fait fi des jeux très vite il ya
j'avais fait un reportage dont il ya un
an sur les sur les militaires qui avait
le blues à cause du poids du plan
sentinelle et qui avait même certains
lâchent et l'armée à cause de ça parce
que ça me correspondait pas du tout à ce
pourquoi ils étaient engagés il faut
savoir que vraiment le plan sentinelle
change la nature du métier militaire on
passe d'une un métier où il avait appris
au moins un tiers de leur temps en opex
normalement avec 1 aux tirs réservé à la
formation
aujourd'hui c'est complètement grignotée
par par la sentinelle donc ils partent
beaucoup moins opération ils ont
beaucoup moins de formation ce qui fait
une armée de moins bonne qualité de
moins bien formés et en plus des
militaires qui se pose est plus
vulnérable parce qu'il faut savoir que
le quotidien d'une mission essentielle
c'est vraiment le métier de vigile c'est
pas pour ça que les gens vont armes et
s'engagent dans l'armée
et ça en fait des espèces de cible
ambulante donc évidemment il ya
énormément de critiques de la part
d'experts sur ce plan social et sa
durabilité
donc il fallait qu'ils changent il me
semble que là les mesures qui consistent
notamment à en faire quelque chose de
beaucoup plus mobile alley de mon sens
sachant qu'il est quand même très
compliqué de réduire le nombre de
militaires dans un contexte de
terroristes parce qu'évidemment donc les
guerrières d'îlots il faudrait plutôt
augmenter les heures supplémentaires des
gendarmes et des policiers c'est ça qui
serait par exemple mais les gendarmes et
policiers sont eux-mêmes à ses déboires
de ces parcelles de vasco mi temps parce
que ces deux réalités qui sont
particulières il ya évidemment besoin de
d'argent et de moyens et d'hommes une
salle intérieure chez les policiers les
gendarmes c'est une réalité en face et
parents brossard
il a imaginé des milices civiles ou non
mais c'est difficile mais des comme le
service civique par exemple faut former
des personnes qui soient pas forcément
entièrement des militaires mais qu'une
formation un peu militaire qu'ils
puissent patrouiller c'était des
provisions qui avaient été mis sur le
tapis qui sera un peu des deux mini
terrain j'ai bien plus vous puisque vous
avez fait le portage année dernière mais
c'est encore plus aujourd'hui c'est des
gens qui sont là quand même attention
c'est le phénomène de cette semaine à
goûter au contraire est bien évidemment
de
yachts et de leurs syndicats leur
dévouement évidemment au combien mais
qui face à cette réalité là sont là sont
épuisés sont à bout et sans en situation
en parler de peur tout à l'heure là en
l'occurrence le prénom pour la santé
l'attitude menaçante on a vu quand même
pas mal de colère sur facebook
beaucoup de collègues et puis surtout
pas comme vous le disiez ils n'ont pas
toujours la possibilité de s'exprimer
donc les réseaux ils peuvent les
utiliser par leur tiers enfin par leur
famille pour s'exprimer et on sent
beaucoup de fatigue beaucoup de
lassitude
il ya même des concours photo comme vous
le savez qui circulent pour dénoncer
l'état du matériel alors c'était plutôt
dans les commissariats mais cet été
c'était un peu partout et donc ça
participe à ce sentiment la population
sent bien qu'ils sont fatigués en même
temps qu'ils ont besoin d'eux et donc
beaucoup de messages toujours de soutien
pour eux et d'incompréhension de cette
situation avec laquelle qui
incompréhension de provoquer question 3
au quatri c'est ce que on n'a pas la
même polémique avec sentinelle qu'on a
eue avec la police de proximité je serai
pas comme on lance un débat sur les
afriques s'imiter mais au sens où on a
pensé que les militaires pouvaient faire
justement être c'est un petit peu du
kaki pour rassurer mais qui n'a pas
vraiment d'efficacité un militaire ce
matin vous vous l'évoquez tout à l'heure
alors ans a encore été agressé au
couteau dans le métro est ce que c'est
pas le signe de l'inefficacité de cette
opération en tous les cas c'est la
question qu'on vous pose aujourd'hui sur
le figaro dans le sur lefigaro.fr et
pouvait continuer à y répondre
c'est difficile parce que je crois que
c'est johnny qui disait tout à l'heure
ses terres qu'il ya c'est difficile de
remettre en question l'opération
sentinelle la présence militaire dans
les rues parce que ça peut on parler de
sa cause une politique et un problème de
deux ans une fois on revient cité de
peur et de rassurance quoi j'ai quelque
chose qui aujourd'hui si on supprime l
opération sentinel telle qu'elle est ce
serait une catastrophe
donc après c'est la mobilisation des
moyens je crois que le parallèle avec la
police de proximité n'est pas n'est pas
juste je crois que c'est pas quelque
chose qui qu'ils soient comparables
je crois que d'une part il ya des
individus ça a été dit aussi qu'ils sont
militaires des hommes qui sont des
hommes et les femmes qui s'engagent dans
l'armée pas pour ça que cette opération
ait l'air plus répondu à une dimension
politique une dimension militaire
et puis après encore une fois je suis
désolé de revenir à ça mais c'est des
gens qui ont besoin de tourner et qui
ont besoin de bouger c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'armée comme la police a
besoin d'hommes et d'argent et encore
une fois ça pose la question on a géré
tout ça dans l'urgence ça pose la
question du long terme de la
structuration et de la politique
générale de sécurité est ce que ces
soldats font partie d'une en vigipirate
demande rachel non c'est le plan
vigipirate qui a été donné en sentinelle
en état d'urgence
donc il n'ya plus de à proprement parler
je parle sous notre contrôle de
vigipirate
il n'y a pas de plan il ya un plan
vigipirate en tout cas il ya un plan
sentinelle et des profs des chefs des
forces de l'ordre qui sont déployés à la
courneuve pour protéger la fête de
l'humanité
donc c'est là qu'on va aller je sais ça
fait rire le figaro qui parle de la fête
de l'huma mais ça fait ou à rire jean
luc mélenchon qui a snobé cette année la
fête est ce d'avoir ce mauvais de cette
fête mais ça fait pas rien non plus ian
brossât adjoint communiste de anne
hidalgo qui était l'invité du talk et de
mathilde de sirop amis surfeurs alive on
les écoute jean luc mélenchon a son
propre agenda son agenda personnel mais
je crois aussi que beaucoup de
responsables de la france insoumise
notamment de députés de la france
insoumise serons présents parce que
personne à gauche ne peut faire une
croix sur un aussi grand rassemblement
que la scène de l'humain oui il est
pourtant jean-luc mélenchon à feu
[Musique]
lacroix et apparemment il ne le regrette
pas en tout cas pas une boule a pas dit
dans marianne ah non il regrette pas du
tout il est dit les au dessus tout ça je
pense qu il est il est au dessus des au
delà elle et elle est passionnante est à
vous de nous plus en cette semaine de
renaud dély et marc endeweld en ont
recueilli assez longuement c'est à vous
qui est long on peut ne pas évidemment
partagé les points de vue les analyses
de jean luc mélenchon mais il la lui a
donné l'occasion et le temps de
s'exprimer et on voit qu'il ya une vraie
logique une vraie stratégie on s'en
doutait on le savait mais il ya quelque
chose d'assez charpenté dans son
explication et vous voulez en venir
jouer quand même cette autre déclaration
de jean luc mélenchon cette semaine
c'était dans dans la provence
et cette fois ci il vise et benoît hamon
benoît hamon n'a pas été capable de
prendre la décision qu'il fallait
prendre c'est à dire se retirer lors de
la course à la présidentielle s'il
s'était retirée il serait aujourd'hui
premier ministre et moi président de la
république franchement vous y croyez
alors il est intéressant mais je pense
qu'effectivement comme dirait qu'il est
il est au dessus se situe très au dessus
d'ailleurs il se situe en face à face
avec un média macro et d'ailleurs je
suis l'opposition et effectivement il
est l'opposition il est le président
tous la frontière a l'air assez ténues
dans son esprit et ce face à face est
intéressant parce qu'il se fait que la
complexité des manuels macro qui qui a
comme en une un intérêt dans ce sondage
impasse puisque des mélenchon 6 et les
meilleurs à ce qu'il dit dans l'intérim
alors sais plus quel meilleur ami je
pense qu'en fait c'est un couple qui
peut durer et ça mais c'est un couple
qui se fait du mal puisqu'en fait macro
on se dit ce mélenchon
il n'est pas crédible et il est excessif
et mélenchon se dit macway n'a rien
compris d'ailleurs lizin et autres qui
se répondent dans l'interview lundi
macro n'a rien compris et macron dit
mélenchon n'a pas de programme pour les
déshérités et d'ailleurs vous dites
c'est jean luc mélenchon répond ah oui
oui mais voilà le paradis des formes
très amusant et malgré tout ce couple se
fait du mal parce que l'un fait un
travail de sape ac qui peut être assez
productif un mélenchon a très bien
compris que la lgv au travail c'était
pas gagné mais que par contre il allait
essayer de fédérer internés contentement
mais inversement mélenchon peut se
marine le pen ise c'est à dire perdre
stature présidentielle dans des excès
verbaux alors les menaces si vous avez
certes sur libé à l'interview d'art il
le dit ça vous avez raison de souligner
ça parce que il est dans une logique qui
revient un peu à celle de la campagne
présidentielle d'apaisement d'ailleurs
encore une forme revient sur la peur ce
après prêtresse de la thématique de la
delà de la soirée il parle lui même de
sa peur qu'il a peur et en sang et
toutes les critiques en volume en est
autant lui demande ce mélenchon bashing
ça vous plaît sinon c'est très pénible
mais avant et judicaël la haine des
médias me donne toujours une chance oui
de toute l'interview vous sentez que ya
pas vraiment de l'abaissement oui mais
ça rappelle surtout c'est le lieu il ya
eu il a gagné beaucoup de sa campagne
alors qu'en changeant son image on le
sait tous entre l'image du candidat de
2007 et celui de 2012 et 2017 c'est est
radicalement différent et pays au
lendemain de la présidentielle avec ses
600 mille voix dont on sent bien encore
qu'il s'est pas passé il finit quatrième
et pour lui il était 2e et qui devait
gagner donc ça n'est toujours pas passé
et donc il ya eu une espèce de 2,2 temps
qui s'est fait plus brutale la critique
l'abaissement voilà quand même
l'apaisement dans vos colonnes n'est pas
forcément les colonnes de la provence
si vous me permettez laurence frais
quand on revoit cette autre déclaration
qu'il fait à propos du parti socialiste
le parti socialiste est aujourd'hui le
seul zoo de france où les animaux se
garde entre eux et ce qui m'a beaucoup
amusé c'est la réplique de françois
kalfon faut proposer qu est ce que la
mouche du coche ou l'abeille qui pique
la place dans ce zoo gardé par les
animaux c'est une formule une boutade
pour dire qu'en réalité les français
attendent autre chose que l'amertume de
jean luc mélenchon quand à la dernière
élection présidentielle
et puis c'est un peu étrange de vouloir
finalement l' alliance avec les
socialistes et de commencé par insulter
ceux qui sont fils ange supposément ses
partenaires oui le fait pas avec ça vous
disiez il est au dessus de tout ça il
voit la métro un peu en majesté au
dessus de la gauche je suis le premier
de cordée dit-il dans dans l'interview
il a chopé la grosse mais il est pas
seulement il trône pas seulement au
dessus de la gauche aujourd'hui on sait
le deuxième titre de la manchette de
l'interview il est peu au cou l'opposant
est pas un opposant il brûle courageuse
en plus imposantes marine le pen
d'ailleurs mais oui parce que par sa
présence par son omniprésence encore une
fois marine le pen
on en a parlé je crois ici la semaine
dernière il ya eu son rendez vous de la
semaine dernière il a fait à peu près 15
lignes dans les journaux et dans les
télévisions et sur les réseaux vous nous
le dira et est aujourd'hui qu'on le
veuille ou non le constat qu'on peut
faire c'est que jean luc mélenchon est
aujourd'hui et quand laurent se disait à
juste titre qu'il ya une espèce de deux
face à face de tête à tête
ils se nourrissent le nez le nez l'autre
aussi parce qu'il bénéficie de l'absence
de la déliquescence du parti socialiste
c'est facile de parler du zoo de son
parti socialiste il n'y a plus rien donc
que vous qu'est ce que la droite a par
ailleurs ses propres problèmes et ses
propres sa propre déliquescence donc
aujourd'hui il est le seul donc il est
au dessus il est au delà il se vit en
tous les cas je ne sais pas si ça durera
pendant très longtemps dans tous les cas
aujourd'hui et je pense que c'est parti
pour durer
pour qu'il soit le leader de cette
opposition qui dépasse la gauche c'est
comme ça que vous le voyez au silence
vous disiez ce qu'il a la grosse tête
en tout cas dans ce face à face et le
mimétisme je trouvais quand même assez
fort parce que là par exemple il est à
lille et à les bouder sur les îles et
d'ailleurs il fait comme macro et dit je
me suis mise en loge avec la fin du
match sur les huit mois qui décident
l'automne le temps médiatique et c'est
moi qui décide et non la barrette
détestation des journalistes il ya plein
de par alice mais il assume et ils
disent les deux opposants savent que
quand vous dites qu'il est le meilleur
ennemi en tout l'été les meilleurs
ennemis en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'il
veut installer la confrontation pourrait
qu'il dit dans leurs locaux ils
profitent de ce vide
je n'ai oui et je peux mais je pense
qu'il faut pas être dupe aussi que ça
sert énormément emmanuel macron d'avoir
comme opposant principal jean luc
mélenchon et notamment au corps parce
que il est c'est très bien que jean luc
mélenchon et est un épouvantail
antisystème comme marine le pen qui a
très peu de chances d'accéder au pouvoir
et ça l'arrangé énormément d'avoir un
opposant aussi finalement caricatural et
aussi qui fait autant aussi peur parce
que mes jean luc mélenchon fait peur à
une amende français est d'ailleurs le
problème le venezuela hainard m'en
coûter aussi à jean luc mélenchon ça
quel grand public au dessus dans sa
crédibilité il est d'ailleurs dans
l'interview il ne lâche rien motion et
les traitements lourds de l'opposition
avaient beau c'est très intéressant
parce que c'est très très dur et
pourquoi jean luc mélenchon ne lâche
rien sur venezuela c'est parce que son
logiciel idéologique qui se lit du
populisme de gauche provient directement
du chavisme vient chantal mouffe et
gijon qui ont écrit leurs livres sur le
populisme sud américain il a vraiment il
est dans ce logiciel a donc s'y noie le
venezuela
moi oui tout son idée mais marqueur
idéologique face à lui ce qu'il est
c'est vraiment de la wii bien et c'est
son exemple javel et en plus il ne peut
pas aujourd'hui revenir nous pondération
s'il peut plus y a pas de retour en
arrière donc mais rien de tel qu'un
raciste et affalé mes camarades auront
insisté pour il ya une part assez
importante d'ailleurs porn sur
l'ensemble sur le venezuela et vous avez
raison il ne lâche rien il n'ya pas
rester en rade l'opposition
vénézuélienne de nostalgiques de
pinochet
hickman eut ressenti par le haut par la
voie démocratique de cette clé est que
léopold en europe est un fasciste bon il
détecte vos prisons on peut lui
reconnaître et de constance à pour le
couvrir la matière est-ce que mélenchon
a raison de se croire le meilleur
opposant est-ce qu'il a raison de
répondre un maquereau là des éléments de
réponse dans vos sondages aidant nick
reilly cité ceux qui sont publiés
justement dans les pages du figaro qu'on
retrouve dans le figaro.fr non mais avec
le sondage que nous avons fait avec la
doxa le figaro et france info dentsu
consulting en fait c'est clairement jean
luc mélenchon le l'opposant pour les
françaises et il a même pas de débat
globalement comme vous le disiez il se
répondent et c'est plutôt clair pour les
français sans doute ne s'était pas dans
le sondage une question sur le venezuela
vous aurez donné raison sur le fait que
voilà au moins ya une constance et on
comprend pourquoi
après ce qui fait sans doute aussi son
succès c'est qu'il est très actif très
active sur les raisons n'en avait parlé
la semaine dernière
il continue est très actif mais ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que si on
s'amuse à regarder sur les réseaux cette
semaine les trois opposants supposé donc
marine le pen sur évoqué et et monsieur
mélenchon ils ont à peu près les mêmes
volumes donc on se dit tiens à s'est
passé quelque chose sauf que quand on
regarde pour marine le pen ou pour
monsieur évoqué les deux cd commentaires
assez factuels sur leurs prises de
position sur ce qu'ils font ils sont sur
leur agenda alors que quand jean-luc
mélenchon c'est le relais de ces propos
c'est presque des soutiens des
engagements ou les critiques fortes mais
on voit que en tout cas il fait réagir
fortement réagir et puis je ne pense pas
que monsieur macron l'ait fait exprès
mais le sujet des feignants
et ce fameux cette fameuse déclaration
mais feignant là quand même sacrément du
service et ça c'est l'autre enseignement
de votre sondage c'est que les propos de
macron sur les feignants sont
globalement désapprouvée par les
français pour 60% des français ils sont
désapprouvés et après quand on regarde
ce qui s'est passé pendant les
manifestations
on pouvait constater en tout cas sur les
réseaux sociaux clairement que pour les
français c'était très bien de manifester
mais qu'il y avait quand même peu de
chances pour que ça donne quoi que ce
soit les uns et les autres est bon il
faut manifester mais voilà par contre
cette manifestation s'est presque
transformé en manifestation anti
feignant c'est à dire qu'en fait cet
argument est devenu évident car voilà et
en fait c'était de dire d'un descendant
dans la rue pour dire que non on ne peut
pas dire ça aux français nous ne sommes
ni signé ni feignants et donc finalement
ça a donné
bré la verrière pour pour justement
est-ce que ça peut me remettre selon
vous un euro dans la machine pour les
contestations de sont prévues la semaine
prochaine jeudi prochain et puis la
marche de mélenchon samedi prochain
c'est le genre de déclarations et de
petites phrases et deux mots qui sont
dévastateurs qui sont assez proches de
la stupidité politique quand même parce
que dans une phase où finalement les
choses étaient relativement sensor de la
part de macron c'est un dérapage pensée
ou c'était calculé avec les handisports
donc il a rajouté en parlant donc c'est
vraiment plus fort oui oui j'ai plutôt
l'impression quelque chose qui est assez
qui vient du casse et après il dit que
c'était pas les français qui le visaient
enfin bon quand on écoute le son propos
on a du mal à penser que c'était la
référence beau fixe pour mobiliser
les autres c'est pas très agréable et
traiter de finir je j'ai entendu génie
critiqué macron je rappelle que vous
êtes rédactrice en chef de la revue
limites ou une critique le capitalisme
financier le libéralisme et on promeut
l'écologie quand mélenchon critique
justement dans l'interview de marianne
la modernité la marchandisation
généralisée et réclame le temps long où
l'harmonie avec les cycles de la nature
selon vous pleurent que je n'entrais un
instant il ya certains à droite qui
s'érige contre la marchandisation de
tous et notamment du vivant il a bien
raison et d'ailleurs il ya une droite
anti libérale qui existe et qui est un
courant vers le libéralisme a été
inventé par la gauche
rappelons le est donc la raison là
dessus et je suis très déçu le succès
jean luc mélenchon il ne descend pas du
ciel il ya eu aussi une vraie
contestation populaire du des excès du
libéralisme et les gens ne sont enfin
pas spontanément d'accord avec les
réformes de macro sur le marché du
travail et toute cette espèce de tous et
toutes ces réformes pour faire entrer la
france dans le nouveau monde s'est il ya
quand même une vraie contestation
d'antan dans tous les pays d'europe pas
seulement en france on a eu beau
dénoncer en espagne et en grèce syriza
donc il ya une vraie inquiétude parce
que il faut enfin les sociétés
occidentales sont de plus en plus
inégalitaire dans thomas piketty n'a
montré très très bien dans ses travaux
il ya des inégalités croissantes et
émaillée macro ne semble pas répondre à
cette angoisse la cette espèce de peur
de déclassement et sa dignité des
inégalités donc le ressorts idéologiques
jan mayen jour il n'est pas du tout
juste communicationnel il appuie sur
quelque chose de profond qui une
angoisse économique et il appuie
également sur certains arts sentiment à
gauche jean baptiste émergents qui suit
les réseaux sociaux qui les scrutent
toute la journée
l'a bien constaté il ya une guerre donc
à gauche
elle est dans les médias dans les
parties sur les réseaux et le web vous
avez compté les points toute cette
semaine et
vous allez vous avez sélectionné des
meilleurs épisodes de cette guerre
qu'elle est quels sont les derniers
épisodes de la série
le match a été très intéressant quand
même on a eu une manifestation mardi
effectivement il y avait des fainéants
dans tous les sens effectivement ça
récupérer un petit peu ces vieilles ces
dérapages une fois qu'on a pu qualifier
dérapage et puis aussi naturellement sur
les réseaux sociaux beaucoup de tweets
et beaucoup de facebook live sur ce
sujet moi j'ai un petit peu regardé
comment avait réagi certains comptes
twitter de gauche par rapport à ses
déclarations envoyées aux interviews
jean luc mélenchon suis allé sur le site
de marianne où j'ai vu que alan quine
disait que le problème est que mélenchon
a raison sur l analyse et pas sur les
solutions et il n'y a que lui pour faire
opposition à macron qui du coup à force
dans du beurre effectivement c'est ce
que tu disais vous disiez tout à l'heure
jenny foulée par rapport à toi quotidien
mais que c'est exactement ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure qui est voilà il
ya un positionnement est en fait il est
utile mélenchon est utile j'ai continué
un petit peu sur les antilles
mélenchonistes avec san qui pense
surtout que jean luc mélenchon rêve d'un
mélenchonisme autoritaire et réagit à
caen jean luc mélenchon dit que mâcon
rêve d'un libéralisme autorise donc ça
forcément ça fonctionne quand tu te suis
allé voir d'autres constructeurs qui
sont qui s'identifient comme à gauche
josé notamment qui dit dans cette
biographie qu'il est de gauche
et de deux durée il a aussi la dent dure
et il dit dans les catégories fainéants
cynique et extrême je dirais que
mélenchon et des trois à la fois on peut
y ajouter guignols s'interroge-t-il
donc il a quand même dit assez fort des
wachowski les valets on peut on peut
dire que mélenchon ans il ya une chose
qui n'est pas ces feignants non mais en
tout cas n'ont pas dire effectivement il
est pas gênant c'est vrai c'est vrai en
tout cas effectivement il était très
présent on l'a beaucoup vu ces derniers
temps et justement alain camélia ricky
qui réagit aussi dit avoir le coeur à
gauche lui mélenchon à brouter l'herbe
du zoo solférino pendant 30 ans puis
bien gras s'est évadé pour se vautrer
dans la fange de la jungle populiste au
fait beau c'est d'ailleurs il deale et
au peuple plus qu'à gauche
et là il faisait part il existe peu le
mans gauche utilise les mots peuple et
ce qui est vraiment la révolte populaire
lancée hier nicolas sarkozy jack carter
c'est ce qui se renvoient le vieux monde
à la figure c'est celui qui sera qui
basculera dans l'un et l'autre se
renvoient à maquereau on dit que c'est
là enfin l'un et l'autre sur moi et
m'ont dit tu verras gagner c'est celui
qui fera basculer dans le vide
dès que mes palmes moderne c'est lui le
modèle oui mais il se dit nous il dit
nous sommes les deux fois ce que dégage
in est donc un cas qui restera la fin
c'est celui qui ne sera pas soumis
violences des deux côtés un peu théâtral
j'ai un dernier tweet de trinity qui dit
martinez snob mélenchon qui tape sur
ramon qui court avec martinez et
mélenchon manque plus que l'amc en plus
l'amant dans le placard et on a du
feydeau exactement ça c'est un jeu comme
ça un couple qui pouvait durer mais qui
fait du mal voilà et avec eux avec
laurence vous pourrez écrire la suite da
sud de la ville est si beaucoup merci
beaucoup jean baptiste ça fait beaucoup
réagir il ya un autre sujet qui fait
beaucoup réagir je pense que vous allez
on va le voir sur les formes du figaro
c'est la paix la pma c'est l'actualité
d'ailleurs cette semaine l'ouverture de
la pma toutes les femmes c'est en tout
cas la non ce mardi de martens il n'y a
pas de secrétaire richard d'état chargée
de l'égalité hommes femmes
alors à gauche on applaudit comme un
mariage l'édito de renaud dély
aujourd'hui et à droite par contre on
est embarrassé en tout cas quand on
s'appelle gérard lâché et on l'écoutera
ensuite jean-françois coupé mais d'abord
on écoute le président du sénat un peu
embêté ce matin c'est un sujet grave qui
touche des femmes qui ne pour certaines
ne peuvent pas avoir d'enfant et donc on
ne le traite pas comme ça au fil
deuxièmement on ne peut pas se réchauffe
rire un espèce de débats clivants dans
notre société révoqué par exemple
reprend à son compte la thèse de sens
commun qui dit pma égale gpa est ce que
vous mettez le signe égal j'avais jean
leonetti 10 et la location des ventres
c'est grave
donc je crois que ça n'est pas la même
chose même si je ne méconnais pas une
certaine porosité
alors on a du mal à connaître la réponse
de gérard larcher et on a également eu
du mal à comprendre celle de jean
françois copé ce matin sur france info
on écoute moi je pense que sur ce sujet
et il faut évoluer et donc pour ma part
je ne m'y opposerais pas
en revanche je fais une différence très
fermes et très clairs par rapport à la
gpa la gestation pour autrui dont le
terme même montre bien que là il s'agit
de la marchandisation des corps dans ce
qu'elle a de plus abject
alors justement guillaume tabard ce
matin dans le figaro dit que précisément
le la
l'évolution avec la pma rouvert pour
tout c'est que on est on est plus dans
une évolution dans un changement qui
conduira inéluctablement à la gpa qu'est
ce que vous en pensez jamais ce qui est
intéressant c'est m'ont parlé de
vaudeville tout à l'heure
l'histoire de ce peuple de droite et
celle d'un immense et permanent
cocufiage puisque les dirigeants de
droite passent leur temps à se renier
yahya yahya trompé en fait les gens qui
leur ont fait confiance puisque les
personnes qu'on vient de voir gérard
larcher mais aussi on pourrait citer
valérie pécresse jean françois copé
était la manif pour tous au premier rang
se montrer devant les caméras et sur ces
questions là vous continuez à nous poser
vos questions la donne et on les a vu
rogner voilà progressivement leur
mission et en fait on a vraiment le
sentiment d'une droite qui à la remorque
de la gauche et qui finalement ne fait
que le fait d'avoir un train dans un
train de retard c'est qu'une fois que le
magnifique pour tous est votée vingt
deux ans après on dit qu'on est con et
tu es con et pour la pma et c est donc
il ya ce sentiment de sentiment d'une
spirale inéluctable d'une droite qui
finalement n'est qu'une gauche plus
lente et qui finalement ne fait que est
arrivé un peu plus tard sans avoir de
véritables convictions ancrées et
permanente c'est assez catastrophique je
pense pour l'image que se font les gens
à droite
après on peut dire que c'est compliqué
on peut dire qu'on ne sera difficile de
revenir dessus mais de dire qu'on a
changé d'avis et qu'on change la vie
parce que c'est une évolution
inéluctable c'est quand même assez
d'envoi et comment les gens peuvent
croire ensuite qu'on va dire non la gta
puisque ces gens là ces gens là qui
disent on est contre la gpa aujourd'hui
disait qu'ils étaient contre la paix
manière non quelle crédibilité alors
j'en ai créé salt avant de continuer le
débat vous sentez quand même dans les
réseaux une fracture entre comme le
sous-entend gildas y ait une fracture
entre le sommet et la base occasion le
sujet il a regardé aussi les volumes
parce qu'en fait on utilise des outils
comme thomas hautcoeur par exemple sont
des outils qui vous permettent de faire
de mesurer le volume et de regarder
aussi où on en parle en fait quand on a
un débat de société on n'en parle plus
tôt sur facebook et pour le moment les
vous
sur facebook sont encore assez limitée
quand on est gosse sur twitter plus tard
tous les français ne sont pas dessus
c'est passionnant très drôle il ya
vincent jay sur le chap qui nous disait
tout à l'heure à propos de mélenchon le
drame c'est d'être trop égocentrique et
trop agressif envers les électeurs qui
lui sont récalcitrants il fait peur
maintenant on attend sa réaction sur les
pma vidéo voilà donc on va dire que sur
les forums ou si c'est un lieu où vous
avez des débats de société cirque on
peut se parler en échanger des arguments
et c'est ce que j'ai pu constater en
regardant depuis des déclarations de
madame schiappa on s'aperçoit que
finalement d'abord parce que c'est elle
qui l'a dit je suis désolée mais en
règle générale ces propos étant parfois
confus et ses annonces nombreuses les
intervalles a été assez clair
sans camion reconnaître dans la jean
jacques bourdin qui l'a appelé en
vérifier la avait clarifié en fait
derrière ils attendent de savoir voilà
est-ce que ça va vraiment être un sujet
au delà d'une déclaration de la ministre
mais on ne sent pas encore un débat de
société on ne sent pas encore que on est
reparti pour les discussions qu'il ya eu
au moment de la manif pour tous ou là
c'était vraiment des débats profonds il
y avait vraiment une société qui s'était
divisée en deux au sein de mêmes
familles on s'apercevait qu'il y avait
des débats lourds en particulier sur
facebook ou sur des forums là pour le
moment c'est une discussion mais on a
encore dans un registre de commentaires
il n'ya pas des mandats on est pas mal
d'engagement ça vous paraît bien le
débat que gérard larcher appelle de ses
voeux
de cotis je trouve que la façon d'en
c'est pourquoi est ce que il n'ya pas de
débats et de polémiques parce que je
trouve que on a suffisamment ou avec un
mois critiques et macro tout à l'heure
pour la trouver que la façon dont tu es
amené déposer les termes du débat est
assez apaisés
d'une part c'était une promesse de
campagne dire que personne ne peut être
surpris aujourd'hui que les choses
arrivent c'était ça a été dit et
claironné c'était quelque chose qui
était assez clair durant la campagne
peut pas dire qu'il présente ce en
cachette il le fait quand même rouvrir
le débat
non mais le fait il ya quelque chose qui
a été dit très important et c'est de
couper de façon très claire d'une part
de dire on va pas faire ça dans la
précipitation on en parle aujourd'hui et
ce sera dans la loi bioéthique de
l'année prochaine et puis d'être très
clair sur la gpa en disant on est
absolument clair il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté là-dessus et déjà et dans le
samyn simplement là dessus ce que dit
guillaume tabard dans son édito c'est
aussi pour ça que à partir de ce
moment-là et de simplement un mot pour
répondre à un génie ou alors c'est qu'il
avait une partie de la droite qui est
allé à la manif pour tous et ensuite la
défaite de sens commun à la
présidentielle mais qui étaient sur des
positions plus opportuniste que
déposition d'une femme de conviction
fondamentale et pour rebondir ce que
vous disiez vous êtes habile c'est que
le seul mot qui ressort beaucoup associé
c'est le mot justice sociale qui n'était
pas forcément un mot qui étaient
associés dans les débats commencent
alors à lens
moi je dirais plutôt que si le lemon
héberge passé quelque part il est
interdit
finalement il est extrêmement difficile
de s'exprimer sur ce sujet sans être
immédiate id immédiatement catalogué
soient conservateurs parce qu'elle
supporte à part certains mais ou
d'étrangers dans la fachosphère ou
d'être qualifié de moi supporter quand
le conservateur au figaro où on a
certains qui là dessus
évidemment si on le pressentait que je
veux dire voilà en tout cas
immédiatement l'argumentation est assez
difficile et parfois ils rouvrent parce
qu'il n'y a pas de raison normalement si
ce sujet n'était pas fièrement truffe
est à bout il devrait être possible de
s'interroger sur l'intérêt de l'enfant à
être privé
de père ou de mère au moins sur le point
symbolique ce débat devrait être
possible de même que celui des femmes à
porter un enfant pour le compte de tiers
parce que vous posiez la question
évidemment que cette immédiatement la
question qui suit derrière puisque
l'argument qui est le plus souvent
avancé c'est la justice sociale si on se
place du point de vue du désir de
l'adulte de l'égalité de la
non-discrimination évidemment que au
désir de défendre d'avoir un enfant
succède le plaisir de deux hommes
d'avoir un enfant ça c'est ça me paraît
absolument mathématiques et d'ailleurs
tous les déroulements des dernières
années a montré que ce mouvement était
inéluctable après si ce débat est
interdite on voit qu'effectivement les
positions voilà effectivement jean
françois copé a changé d'avis alors
était-il sincère où il est il hier les
tirs aujourd'hui quelque part je vais
peut-être une idée quand même que ce nom
mais est ce que je constate c'est que
vient je crois je suis pas sûr que ce
débat ait lieu et on ne peut que le
regretter mais alors ça devrait être
rassurante si le psy l'elysée veut un
grand débat justement il va falloir un
débat puisque de manière on ne sait pas
comment concrètement cette loi va être
mis en avant les problèmes très concrets
qui ce qui se pose par exemple l'article
312 du code civil je crois qu'il paraît
qu'ils parlent de la présomption de
paternité
dans le cas dans le cadre d'un mariage
c'est à dire quand la fameux commencé en
temps on considère que c'est le père qui
est avec qui marie avec la femme qui le
père voit la présomption jusqu'à ce que
le contraire soit prouvée par tester
dette par exemple et là comme on va
faire est-ce qu'on va réécrire la
présomption de paternité en présomption
de parenté ça c'est un vrai débat où est
ce qu'on va faire encore on va instituer
une filiation symbolique et la question
de l'anonymat des donneurs qui est
vraiment très importante est ce que on
va continuer à faire de l'anonymat des
donneurs si on ne le fait plus il y aura
plus du tout du tout que d'émettre des
chèques en a pas beaucoup
donc il ya des vraies questions de mise
en oeuvre même de cette mesure cliquez
pas et qu'il n'y ait pas évidente et qui
va créer des débris de l'arc c'est pour
ça que je trouve que c'est je voudrais
dire
laurence mais que le fait qu'ils aient
pas de précipitation on annonce rend le
débat possible dans tous les coeurs
c'est pour ça que je ne comprends pas
bien laurence le débat il est interdit
mais ils interviewent les pas interdit
au figaro il n'est pas interdit à
marianne le débat à ce qui est peut-être
des gens en tout cas marianne maintenant
8 en faveur de problèmes du débat est
vrai mais il ya des gens qui ne veulent
plus débattre aujourd'hui
et là ça renvoie plutôt à des gens de
droite qui finalement relancée mais je
trouve que le débat on a débattu pendant
des années autour de du mariage pour
tous est de 2 ne peux pas dire que j'ai
du mal à considérer le débat est
interdite il ya une diabolisation de
l'adversaire même l'édito de renault et
me dit qu'en volé quelques illuminés les
éliminer les illuminés qui sont posés ça
qu'ils sont vraiment une espèce de enfin
des reins des ringards qui n'ont rien
compris mais sans aucun sens de
l'histoire c'est pas celle ci est à
respecter l'adversaire c'est pas ça qui
interdit le débat mais ça ne sera pas du
rendez vous majeur et un éditorial qui
fait que des commissions c'est pas en
général c'est quand même une unité de
ringardisation adversaires et l'idée
qu'il y aurait un sens de l'histoire une
adulte avec de toute façon cette
opposition n'est pas légitime une
délégitimation
elle est partout mais elle est quand
même très très visible et la
contestation y compris virulentes d'un
contradicteur n'interdit pas nullement ô
combien est heureusement aux
contradicteurs de s'exprimer autant et
aussi bien qu'élevé j'ai l'impression
que ça existe à près partout et dieu
merci
heureusement on est dans ce débat qui
tout de suite devient passionnel dès
qu'un argument est avancé
le ton monte et du coup on arrive on va
pas refaire ça s'en va quitter la
société
et du coup on referme ce débat on
n'aborde pas les vraies questions
et quand vous savez que c'est plutôt
river
j'ai plutôt sélectionne c'est certain et
vers la droite
aujourd'hui si elle recule c'est parce
qu'elle a peur qu'elle est tétanisé
d'être traités de réactionnaire et crise
c'est pour ça que les principaux
dirigeants de droite recule ce sujet
c'est peut-être aussi parce que ces
débats malgré tout ils datent pas
d'aujourd'hui il ça fait longtemps qu'il
est ouvert et qui continue c'est pas un
débat qui est simplement qui va être
ouvert parce que marlène schiappa a
lancé une première sera pas parmi les
morts depuis longtemps le nombre
d'intellectuels d'anthropologues de
psychologues
le juriste on a intégré beaucoup dans
fillon mais ailleurs aussi et pas
seulement de droite mais aussi des gens
de gauche
aujourd'hui on a fait l'interview de
nathalie yannick kane sociologue qui est
plutôt classé à gauche qui alarme sur
les conséquences de la pma enfin cette
espèce de voile il ya une vraie
mobilisation intellectuelle de d'experts
et qui ne se reflète pas du tout sur le
plan politique dans la classe politique
et est en fait tout va de soi comme
s'ils avaient aucune opposition est
excusé tout ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on leur fasse vraiment qu'on consacre
en 1h07 cette question là je voudrais
pas me faire que lance me reproche de
faire d'interdire le débat mais
j'aimerais qu'on aborde un dernier point
si le sait les journées du patrimoine se
ce week-end alors vous pouvez aller à
montmartre avec une visite
exceptionnelle où vous retrouverez un
homme qui s'appelle philippe brina scodi
et fait visiter la butte comme personne
c'est une idée de visite pour les
journées du patrimoine et puis si vous
n'êtes pas le temps d'y aller de le
faire avec lui vous retrouvez la vidéo
elle est sur figaro live comme une autre
vidéo du sénat que vous allez voir
laurent j'imagine qu'on retrouve tous
les détails tout ce qu'il faut visiter
dans le figaro.fr absolument il faut
aller sur le figaro.fr et regardez notre
carte interactive également pour
découvrir très insolite à paris en
province bon au risque de tomber dans un
d'autres fidèles à une caricature qu'on
fait du système médiatique en peu de
temps j'aurais qu'on aborde un crise une
question fondamentale c'est que ça va
être un succès on redécouvre les racines
des endroits d'habitude fermée au public
derrière mais est-ce que derrière cette
fête il y à un pas un vrai problème
c'est la disparition voire la
destruction du petit patrimoine qu'on ne
peut qu on peut plus financer ce qu'on
avait lié au milieu de l'été clerc
bodmer qui était spéciale du patrimoine
au figaro et elle explique qu'il ya
énormément de 2,2 de patrimoine de
château de villa qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'abandon détruite parce qu'il ya plus
d'argent pour les pour les financer et
que les collectivités ne peuvent plus
les financer et ça va s'empirer avec la
destruction avec la disparition de la
taxe de la taxe d'habitation qui
finançait justement les impôts locaux
jeu mais je crois que c'est un vrai
problème et comme le disait je sais plus
qui avait cette expression en disant que
le patrimoine c'était vraiment le
pétrole de la france c'est à dire que
n'a pas de pétrole mais on a du
patrimoine c'est ça c'est vraiment un
c'est non seulement un legs du passé
mais c'est aussi un apport énorme pour
la france notamment pour le tourisme
enfin pour tous que le cadre qu'est la
france aujourd'hui et je pense que ce
qu'il faudrait faire et il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui les proposent
d'ailleurs c'est de vous est vraiment le
ministre la culture à la protection à la
préservation et la conservation du
patrimoine que ce soit quasiment une des
missions essentielles voire même
exclusive ministère de la culture qui a
un budget exponentielle d'année en année
et il en consacre une grosse grosse
partie à l'encadrement de la création
artistique donc et peut-être qu'il
faudrait peut-être un peu moins en
consacrer à la création artistique
notamment au spectacle vivant est un peu
plus sur le patrimoine qui a besoin
d'être entretenue et préservé parce
qu'il me semble que c'est quand même la
mission principale aujourd'hui du
ministre de la culture je vois eric
decouty faire l'amour
non parce que l'idée de ce encore une
fois de principe des vases communicants
va enlever au théâtre vivant pour mettre
au patrimoine je pense que là je
je trouve ça veut dire que c'est
dérisoire mais on vend la question du
patrimoine je suis évidemment pas un
spécialiste de beaucoup de choses le
plus ans de ça mais que la question de
la disparition du patrimoine est une
vraie question
mais en revanche je suis à peu près
certain que ce n'est pas en prenant
l'argent au théâtre vivant qu'on
retrouvera le patrimoine les journées du
patrimoine c'est un fait d'un grand
phénomène de schizophrénie collective en
fait parce que pendant deux jours les
français des dizaines millions française
précipitant tous les monuments
historiques qui font des heures de queue
il se passionne on fait des reportages
la plus fine et je vous garantis sur
figaro.fr on va voir des taux de lecture
kraft à dakar s'est déroulé il sera en
direct du crazy horse et que dès le
lendemain dès le lundi matin on va de
nouveau se plonger dans la repentance la
question sur racine pas racine on va
recommencer avant nos châteaux aux
chinois il ya maintenant aux églises aux
enchères sur ebay c'est je sais pas
cessé leur importance mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que sur les réseaux l'or n'en
parle pas si on regarde devant des
missions gérer créateurs n'en parle pas
il est certain que pendant ces journées
on va énormément parler que les uns et
les autres vont se félicite et partager
ces expériences est à peu près certain
que lundi matin n'en parlera plus alors
il ya quand même des initiatives acheter
un château par exemple comme on l'a vu
en dordogne rapidement un lieu que vous
conseillez peut-être
à visiter un code qu'il y avait deux
pouvoirs et puis le théâtre montansier à
versailles montante yannick résulte une
idée d'un nunchuk consulting puisque
l'on parle de bons joueurs mais je
l'inviterai à tous les parisiens à être
des touristes dans paris aller dans des
endroits il se peut mais parce que le
patrimoine il est sous notre nez moi
j'ai fait une seule fois dans ma vie
d'avant une patrimoine je vais à
l'assemblée nationale il ya huit ans et
ça m'a donné on est écouté de la
politique à vis du coup je je pensais
quand-même l'international ses limites
de la mairie de paris moi j'avais fait
ça m'avait pas dégoûté pour autant
j'avais décidé moi je vous recommande le
château de benauge près de bordeaux avec
des animations médiévales les bénévoles
ont travaillé tout l'été pour mettre au
point des jeux médiévaux et un des
planches de chevalier de princesse il ya
but est qu'ils compris ce formidable le
château de chalais où vécut talleyrand
repris par les nih m l'imitateur yves
lecoq avec animation aux costumes
un grand merci à vous un grand merci de
nous avoir suivi et on se retrouve dès
lundi cette fois ci avec guillaume
roquette merci bon week-end sur fear
alive
[Musique]